(chiming music)
- [Teacher] Four plus one is?
- 16.
(laughing)
(celebrating)
- Hi teachers.
Sal Khan here from Khan Academy.
Now I just wanted to make sure that
when congratulations
are being passed around
that we take the time
to say congratulations
and thank you to teachers
for all of the amazing work that they do.
Congratulations for getting
another group of students
forward in their life.
(students applauding)
And I always say, if I had to pick between
an amazing teacher or amazing technology,
I would pick the amazing
teacher every single time.
(celebrating)
But in times where we're having
to lean a little bit more
on the screen, I think it only
highlights that much more,
how invaluable the human element is.
How invaluable the work that
you do to motivate students,
unblock them and form
those human connections.
Are valuable not just for
learning the academic material,
but for making them stronger,
more resilient and better human beings.
(students celebrating)
So thank you so much all of you teachers
in this graduation time for
all of the incredible work
you do day in, day out.
(chiming music)